ce jour 14 de la campagne électorale où
la de la transparence
le premier ministre fait les pouillard
bonjour monsieur khouya bonne humeur
pour les entrevues matinale est une
farce qui ne veut pas vu venir
vous préférez bien établie je pense que
les québécois ce qu'ils souhaitent c'est
un changement changement de ton en tout
cas en fin de matinée c'est après midi
dit qu'est ce que vous faites c'est
poids de vos affaires motion a mis une
petite pique ponctuée d'un de son
ministre candidat quand un problème
mécanique se transforme en argument
politique comme on a fait des milliers
de kilomètres sur les routes laissé dans
un état déplorable par quinze ans de
régime libéral
on a un petit peu de problèmes de
suspension petit écart dans le régime de
campagne mais il se justifie et se
serait dissimulé de l'information oui
parce qu'il aurait manqué de
transparence ici mathieu prost radio
canada je regardais la première vous
avez le temps de regarder ces campagnes
pauvres et le oui
[Musique]